what we're going to think about now is
the if we're given some triangle and
here we have triangle abc what are the
medians of the triangle and how do they
relate to each other and do they have
some interesting properties and you
might guess that they do so the median
is if we start one of the vertices so
let's start at this one right over here
and then we bisect the opposite side so
this right over here would be a median
and so it started there and it bisects
this side right over here so the length
from b to let's call this d is equal to
the length from d to c now let's do that
with every side so i can draw a median
over here
like that so and let's call this point e
so the length from a to e is going to be
equal the length from e to c although i
kind of drew it a little lopsided but
that gets it pretty close and then we're
going to draw another median and i'm not
going to prove it in this video but all
of the medians and this is another neat
thing that you know when you have three
lines that will always intersect at one
point but all the medians do intersect
at one point they all are concurrent
they all hit one common point in the
center so let's draw it that way
i'm not going to prove it in this video
so this length let's call this point
right over here f
so this length right over here
this length right over there is equal to
that length over there and the point at
which these medians intersect is called
the centroid the centroid and when you
start studying physics if you were
actually if this was a uniform triangle
and you were to throw it it would rotate
around the centroid right over here but
we'll just study geometrically for now
so let's call the sten centroid well
we've already gone up to f so let's call
the centroid g
right over there
now what i wanna that by itself is neat
that you have a centroid that if you
were to throw it if it was a uniform
mass that would rotate around the
centroid but what's even neater about
this is that we can see that we've
divided this triangle into six smaller
triangles what's really cool even though
these aren't congruent triangles
necessarily but they do have the same
area and that's what we're going to
prove in this video that these six
triangles all have the same area
now to start off i'm just going to look
at
two i'm going to look at different pairs
of triangles so let's look let's look at
these two triangles right over here
let's look at those two triangles over
here and to show that those two have the
same area we're just going to invoke a
very simple principle so imagine
rotating just those two triangles over
so just rotating just those two
triangles over it would look something
like this
it would look something like this let me
try my best to draw it where this would
be point g
i'll even try to color code it the same
that is point g
that is that side right over there this
is point c
this is point b
that is point b and then this right over
here would be the second part of that
median right over there that over there
would be point d
now we know and i didn't draw it
actually that nicely over here we know
that this length is equal to this length
right over here that these two triangles
if we're starting to think about the
area they have the same base
and we know area area is equal to
one-half
base times height so they definitely
have the same base what about their
heights well they also have the same
heights both of their heights both of
their height is exactly that tall they
both have the same height so both of
them have the same base they both have
the same height on an ob on an obtuse
triangle right here the altitude sits
outside of it so that might be a little
counter-intuitive so if you have an
obtuse triangle like that i say obtuse
because this is more than 90 degrees
your altitude your height will actually
sit outside of the triangle but that's
okay both of these triangles have the
same base and the same height so they
must have the same area so if this air
this one right here has area x this one
right here will have area x as well
and you can use the exact same logic to
say well look this guy and this guy they
have the same base and they both have
the same height so if this one right
over here is of area y then this one
over here is also going to be of area y
they're going to have the same area and
then finally we can do the same thing
for these two characters up here they
both have the same base this was a by bf
is equal to fa and they both have the
same height we drop an altitude like
that and so if we call this area if you
call this area right over here z you
could call that area z as well so so far
we've shown that we can divide this into
three pairs of triangles that have the
same area but we want to now show that
they all have the same area and to do
that we can invoke this same principle
but we'll do it with different sets of
triangles so now let's look at triangle
let's look at triangle bae
look at triangle b a e
triangle b a e so the area of triangle b
a e area of b
a e
is going to be equal to z plus z plus y
z plus z plus y and let's look at the
area of triangle b e c
b e c right over there
that's going to be this triangle right
over here is going to be x plus x plus y
so the area of b e c
is going to be x plus x plus y but the
same principle they both have the same
base and they both have the same height
we could drop an altitude like this this
one is obtuse so that the altitude sits
outside of it but they have the exact
same height so these two areas need to
be equal to each other so you have
z well let me just add that up that you
have 2z
2z plus y is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to 2x
2x plus y 2x plus y subtract y from both
sides you get 2z is equal to 2x divide
both sides by 2 you get z
is equal to x and so we could say we
could write an x here and an x there so
we know that all of these four have the
same area but we still have to worry
about these y's here and to do that we
just have to kind of rotate the way that
we look at it and now look at triangle
adc
let me do that in a different color
let me triangle adc which i'm
highlighting right over here
triangle adc whose area so the area of a
dc is going to be 2y plus x is equal to
2y
plus x and then look at triangle see
what color have i not used yet let me
use this green triangle a
db triangle adb
triangle area of triangle adb
is going to be equal to well you could
say it's 2z plus x but we know that the
z's are equal to x it's really just x
plus x plus x it's really equal to adb
is equal to 3x and we have the same idea
here adb has this base which is the same
as adc's base and they both have the
same height we could drop an altitude
like this could drop an altitude like
that they have the same height we're
just invoking this principle over and
over and over again so these things have
to equal each other
so we get 2y
plus x is equal to 3x
is equal to 3x subtract x from both
sides you get 2y
is equal to 2x
or
or y is equal to x so that's a really
neat result you go from each of the
vertices of a triangle to the opposite
side and you bisect that opposite side
and you do that three times you have
three medians these lines are called
medians where they intersect as a
centroid and what's really cool is it
divides the triangle into six smaller
triangles of equal area